[拍手]
[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
皆さんは科学者というとどんなイメージを持っているでしょうか
例えばバックトゥザフューチャーの毒とかあるいはもうちょっと年齢が上の方ですと
お茶の水ハカセとか
まあいずれにせよこんな感じかなーと思うんですけれども
まあ歳をとっている方で男性というのがひっかく的科学者のイメージとして
あの壁やすいんじゃないかなと思います
では女性の科学者というとどなたを想像するでしょうか
例えばマリキュリー夫人など影ましたかねぇ
でえっと私にとっては自分の母というのがまあ自分の一番身近な女性の科学者だった
わけですけれども
マリキュリー夫人あの確かにノーベル賞を2回も撮った方という意味では男性にも
珍しいというあのいないということなのでそういう意味ではす本当にすごいんです
けれども
ノーベル賞の受賞者
全体の中で女性というのはたった5.8%しかいません
881人中の48人という大変少ない数です
この48人ですけれどもこちらに示すようなあの形なんですけれども
その中でですね chemistry 科学それから physics 物理そして
フィジーロジー and medicine
医学生理学こちらのその受賞者というのは
だった17人しかいません8マリキュリーがに買い取っているので18回なんです
けれども
17人つまり残りの30名ほどは
a まあ深くではないということですね
では一体なぜ女性の科学者というのは少ないんでしょうか
女性は何か科学に向いていないというような適性の違いというのがあるのでしょう
このことについて少し考えてみたいと思います
もちろんその私たちは人間を含めたその
へ
生き物というものは
哺乳類では
有性生殖を行うという生物的なまずさというのがありましてこちらにその
大きい方の x 染色体それから小さい方の y 染色体というのがありますけれども
性の差というのはこの y 染色体を持っているかどうか
こちらでその決まってきます
ねでもこういったその星の里がいうのがあるのはなぜかというとこれが実は非常に強い
robust なぁダイバーシティを生み出す戦略だったんですね
なので私たちヒトを含む哺乳類というのはこう言ったその有性生殖を行いますけれども
そのことに
よってその街球場で非常にその a
まああの反映することができたということになります
猫のような土ピアノ生物学的なその性の差というものが
a 長女に発生が進んで私たちのその身体の中でまぁホルモンがそので付違うことの
ホルモンができるそしてその例えば脳のつくりというのも
このちょっと男女の差があります例えば9にでっ立っている論文からとったものでは
女性の方が脳のその左右のコネクションが強いというようなそういう傾向がありますよ
ということを論文から取ってきていますけれども
でこのようなその脳の違いというのは私たちがどのように世界をに
指揮するかどのように考えるかということにもまあ
影響与えるということはあります例えば
地図の読めない女というような a 今のタイトルがあったの覚えていらっしゃる
でしょうか
8場所日順を覚えるということにおいてその地図的なそのものの考え方というのもあり
ますけれども
でも例えば私の場合ですとあそこの交差点の角にお花屋さんがあってそこを右に曲がっ
てそういったことを2アヌス繰り返して言ってゴールにたどり着くということができる
だからもしボールにたどり着くということが目的であれば
誓ったその考え方をとって
でそれでそのゴールにたどり着いてもいいわけですよね
さて
このようなその生物学的なそのせいさのほかに社会的な性差というのがあります
これジェンダーというふうに言いますけれども
例えば女性だったらそのスカートを着るあーえーと私は今日はちょっとワンピースです
けれども男性だったらズボンをはくあ除染は最近ズボン履く方も多いですね
でこういったその服装の違いだけではなくてたとえば男性は外に出て働きましょう女性
は家庭にこもってそのまま
家のことをしましょうというようなその性別役割分担ということになってしまったとし
たらこれはちょっと問題ではないかなというふうに考えられます
でこのような社会的なそのせいさあというのはいったいそのいつ頃から生まれてくるの
かということに関してかなり若いときあるいは小さい時からのまあ刷り込みというのが
あると考えられます
例えば子どもが
おもちゃで遊ぶ時に
一般的にそのは男の子なドア車のおもちゃでまぁそんで女の子は何かお人形さんレプ
その遊ぶ
まあこのお兄にをさんの場合はですね名前はりかちゃんという名前がついているんです
けれども
でりかちゃんという名前なんですがまぁメルシー nhk は算数の宿題よりずっと
楽しいわ
あるいはそっか理科算数は苦手だけど頑張ってみるねハートというような感じで
リカちゃんなんですけれども
えっとなんか美系は苦手派
というまず設定だったりするこういったことで
まあ小さい時からなんかかわいい女の子は理科が苦手算数が苦手というような刷り込み
ができてしまうようなこともありますね
でさらにそのいろんな州形でその親からあるいは
a 先生からいろんな剃り込みがあります例えばお父さんがお前理系に進学して
書作就職先なんてあるのかな
歩いお母さんがぜひそんなことしたらあなた思いお嫁の貰い手がなくなっちゃうかも
しれないじゃない
まあそんなふうなことを受けるということはあるかもしれません
でも中学2年生の時点で世界的な時計では
男女で男の子女の子で数学や理科んの平均点のその差というのは実はないんですね
れにもかかわらず大学にその進学する時点では日本では男性が3割はゴメンサイサン
サンたい女性が市というような形にまあなってしまう
でまた女性の中にはバリバリとこう仕事をするこれまあ必ずしもその科学者だけでは
ないですけれども
そういうことをすると例えば家庭とそれから仕事を両立させるということが難しいんで
はないかというふうに心配になる人もいるかもしれません
確かにその出産ということは女性しかできない
まあとても大事なあの役割だと思いますけれども
例えば子供を育てるあるいは家庭の中のすることをするというのは男性ができないその
能力がないわけではないですよねですのでこういったことは
あの a 考え感改善できるんじゃないかなというふうに思うんですけれども
さてそうやってその正快適なその精査などを刷り込まれて行く間に
例えばキャリア志向罹患してのジェンダーさというのが生まれます
これは
自然科学系の学会学教会で行った
2万人規模のアンケートなんですけれどもあなたは将来
キャリアとして例えば教授のようになって研究室を主宰したいですか pi になり
たいですかという答え
そしてピアじゃなくてもいいから研究を続けたいと言う
答え女性ですとこれだいたい版あの半々ぐらい同じくらいの割合なんですけれども
同じ問いに対して男性はこういうふうに答えます60%ぐらいの方は自分は最終的に
その研究室の主催する教授になりたい
16パーセントぐらいはそうではない
えーとこれは女性の方がある意味
教授のポジションというのはそんだけないわけですから現実的な考え方をするという
ことでもあるかもしれませんし
男性はものすごくポジティブシンキングだということなのかもしれません
でも結果としてですねこれはどういうことかというと
もしかしたらより優秀かもしれない女性がキャリアを諦めて
でもしかしたら女性よりも優秀ではない男性にそのポジションを取られてしまっている
かもしれない
ということで我が国においてこれは人材が活かされてないんではないかという風に考え
られるわけです
で8これは8 a まあ某企業の例ですけれども
業績が悪くなったときにそれを日カバーするためにダイバースティが大事であるという
ことで成功した
そういったその女性の参画あるいはそのったようなその旗のペットたちがその角すると
いうことが非常に重要なんではないかという風に考えられます
では私からここで3つの a まあメッセージを伝えたいと思うんですけれども
それは
一つ目ですけれどもまず
6色のバイアスに傷つくということです
でそれは
いろんなバイアスがあります男性にも女性にもあります
例えば子どもが保育園に行っていて
で熱が出た
その時にお父さんがじゃあ迎えに行かなきゃってことになると村上司の人が例えば a
君が保育園に迎えに行くの
あるいはリーダーというとつい男性のイメージを持っているのでやリーダーに適した
女性がいないんだよねー
そんな風に思ってしまうなことがあるかもしれません
あるいは女性の方にも
私はこれを白馬の王子様症候群というふうに名付けているんですけれども
ちょっと笑ってもらいましたねはい
例えば女性は自分が優秀だったらがあ
誰かが私のことを良いポジションに引き上げてくれるだから私待ってる
という間に実はそのポジションは誰かポジティブシンキングな男性に捉えてしまうかも
しれないということがありますよね
でもっと自分でその手を挙げるということをした方がいいかもしれない
そして
もう1つ2つ目ですけれどもメンターを持つ
よろモデルを持つという事ですが私にとってはそれはさんの両親でしたしあるいは指導
教員にも非常に助かりましたけれども
東北大学の例ですけれども最初にその日本で初めて女子学生を入学を受け入れたという
まあ輝かしい伝統があるわけです
すがその3人はばけが降ったりかあの数学だったりしました
でこれはどういう人たちに助けられたかというと初代総長がオープンドアポリシー門戸
開放ということを言った
そしてだったらあなたも入れますよということで入学をエンカレッジしたら
永井先生
そしてさらに大学に入学した後に
大学院にも進学したらどうですかと言ってそのさらに宴会でエッチングした
真島先生こう言ったその男性のメンターもいたからということがありますですので男性
もその女性もぜひ女性をエンカレッジしていただけたらいいなというふうに私は思い
ます
最後3つ目ですけれどもそれは今日のテーマにも関わりますけれども
ネットワーキングということです
ねえ道具大学女性の割合は非常に少ないんですけれども大学院生でも4分の1しかい
ませんが私は東北大学にこの3沿線ジェル制度というものを作りました
これは自然科学系の女性の大学院生が手を挙げて
そして早朝から任命される
でで身近なロールモデルとして科学の面白さ楽しさをみんなにその伝えるという役割を
しミッションになっています
例えばオープンキャンパスに出たり出張セミナーをしたりあるいは9カタール a 3
s ホールでも行う
3 s イベントに参加するそういったことで
豆腐大学のその3 s angel さんたちがネットワークをつくりこういう
イベントを行う間にネットワークを作りそれをずっとその
持ち続けてもらえたらいいなというふうに思っています
最後に私の大好きな言葉をご紹介したいというふうに思います
これはフランスの刷毛学者であり
生物学者でもあったルイパスツールという形の言葉なんですけれども
科学に国境はない
という言葉を残していますで8日本語はこの後さらに続く
だが科学者には祖国があるという言葉とセットになっていますこれはその科学には
ボーダーレスである科学はボーダーレスなんだけれどもそれぞれの科学者にその自分の
大事な文化があり
言葉があるということを大事にした方がいいということなんですけれどもこれは私が
今日はこういう言い方に変えたいと思います
科学に性差はない男性がやっても女性がやってもいいことです
でも科学茶にはジェンダーがある
それは異なる視点を持った女性研究者がもっと科学に参画するということがその科学の
進展やイノベーションのか気になるのではないかという風に考えるからです
women にファインズ3 s ニート women
どうもありがとうございました
[拍手]